no Aaron Rodgers yet I guess he's doing
about 20 seconds according to fritzy
yeah tick-tick-tick tick-tick-tick
rogers may have gotten cut now if rogers
is a true fan of the show then he
wouldn't show up because he would know
that you would get apply to the face
Fritzie
or maybe exactly but I'm hurt Todd like
I'm insured that's true I'm sick kidney
stones you're always hurting always sick
what do you think Aaron Rodgers watch
last night football game game tape like
a bad rom-com with Danika Netflix how to
Lose a Guy in 10 days was on HBO last
night at 10:30 Oh looks like fritzy he's
gonna win his damn bet way he's not on
yet not onion I'm gonna say he has to
say he watched football last night
let's bring in Aaron Rodgers Packers
quarterback Aaron how are you today good
Dan Thanks having me back on buddy yeah
we wanted to get you when you had a
perfect game and I guess you had a
perfect game this past weekend right
that's what we're trying to we're trying
to decide what you watched last night
game tape the game itself Jets Patriots
or maybe a Netflix rom-com all of the
above I guess not Netflix though let's
see what was on last night yeah watch
some tape of Kansas City and then a
little bit of the game before it kind of
got out of hand and then what was on TV
no not been that good probably Matthew
McConaughey Kate Hudson movie or
something like that yeah that's what
McLovin said you were probably watching
that movie
roll a little bit yeah we showed that
this morning I mean you brought some
steam you almost broke a window let
alone McLovin you could have killed him
that day have you ever hurt baby ever
broken fingers on the receiver yeah it's
it's actually not a point of pride do
you want those guys hanging on their
fingers but yeah a couple in high school
and up on the league I think probably
yeah we were wondering if Sam darn 'old
was miked up last night and I'm railing
against the Jets that they would mic him
up against the Patriots and he's a
second-year quarterback like can you can
you turn down being miked up in a game
oh yeah have you that point yeah yeah I
would never want to be miked up if I'm a
quarterback you know there's this
sometimes where you thinking it could be
fun to look back down the line I think
Brett was miked up for the game where he
passed Marino maybe in touchdowns and
and it's some pretty cool audio but yeah
I've been like that for a while I don't
know I just feel like it's a little
invasive at times and you know I think
the the ESPN one is why I mean they big
and played quickly did you know there's
a lot more freedom I think when you when
it's films because they can go back and
cut it so it's not you know they're not
watch in real time and then put it up on
the TV I just think that's put you in a
tough spot
but you know what Sam darn old said
during the game no I didn't I wasn't
watching what the sound on he said on
the sidelines I'm seeing ghosts so he's
saying that to his offensive coordinator
I'm seeing ghosts which is not a good
thing for anybody to be on the record as
saying and certainly not a quarterback
yes I mean obviously it looked like a
tough one last night but have you ever
seen ghost Aaron during a game I for me
it's more you maybe just don't see a guy
based on you know offensive defensive
linemen in the way or you just not
looking in that area definitely uh you
know thrown couple bad interceptions
where it looks obviously really bad
because you're throwing it right with a
guy and you just couldn't see him you
know even more look in that direction or
something's in the way and you just
couldn't see him how much fun are you
having now based off of everything that
was said earlier in the offseason the
silly coverage all of that and now where
you guys are I don't have a lot of fun I
really enjoyed this group I mean it's a
it's a fun group of guys you know the
celebrations are crazy I don't you know
I think back I don't know maybe you know
earlier in my career and I don't think
there was this much fun being out on the
field you know like the league crackdown
on some of it and definitely didn't want
a lot of you know group celebrations and
I think it's fun I think it's good for
the game I think you know teams teens
have been doing it you know defense has
been celebrating together offenses and
you know celebrating together and lambo
you know we started turning off the
lights when we you know night game
escort that sounds pretty cool it's
funny I'm having a lot of fun bad he's
he's been a blast to work with and the
grow in our relationship as we get used
to each other you know in in game
situations you know not haven't played
really in the preseason you know it's
been it's been a lot of fun to go
through the weeks of preparation
together and and talk about scheme and
ideas and and then to see it kind of all
come to fruition on on Sundays and in
our keys didn't been fun you know we've
been find ways to win different ways you
know run the ball throw on the ball when
it would defense and I think you know
all three phases of human feeling did
good about where we're at after seven
weeks we had Clay Matthews on a couple
of weeks ago and
you know he was a little hurt that
didn't felt like he gave him an no door
farewell you'd normally do that with
offensive guys and then he said you know
he hopes that he gets invited to the
wedding so I don't I don't know who her
things stand but you know that little
guy had a broken heart I mean I'm just
the middleman here Aaron clay that guy
had a broken heart I love clay and a lot
of the stuff that that I wanted to say
to cook I said in person you know or or
on the phone and yeah I didn't give him
you know a big social media but clay and
I have had a great relationship for a
long time you know he was so fun to work
with for years on those State Farm
commercials and you know we work out of
the same gym in the offseason and any
super fun clan the offseason I mean he's
just he's a lot of fun to be around he's
always cracking up and cutting up
usually you know with me as the butt of
his jokes but yeah you know that that's
a place personality he's always looking
for something he can kind of rib me with
and um you know that was you know what
he was playing sensitive about for
awhile but you know we miss him you know
he's he's obviously you know he's he
started off fantastic to the season and
fortunate that you know that jaw injury
but hopefully gets back here pretty soon
he's Aaron Rodgers the Packers
quarterback Kansas City is up next are
you expecting mahomes to play in this
game I don't know you know I saw the
injury and it looked looked pretty bad
but he just died I mean I wouldn't
wouldn't roll him out it sounds like you
know the MRI went better than expected
out there so I mean I would never rule
that out
I don't know if there's a simple answer
to this but it just you know something
about your touchdown to interception
ratio which is remarkable its all-time
great stuff but how do you avoid
interceptions
well I mean I think the easy answer is
probably some sort of accuracy you know
you're just limiting the the number you
know there's always going to be those
those borderline plays you know but I
think if you're putting the ball and in
pretty good spots you're gonna eliminate
a lot of the opportunities there's some
that you can't get anything about you
know two balls or guys falling down or
slips but the ones that you can you know
placement of footballs I'm seeing a
field and making the proper reeds you
know I think I've been pretty good over
the years of just not throwing too many
of those bad ones you know like I said
earlier where you kind of don't see a
guy just haven't been to many of those
over the years and you know I've had
some guys who can make contested catches
to over the years you know I think James
Jones and dirty and Devon play is really
good and you know that helps obviously
avoid interceptions and I'm just trying
to always be smart with the ball and
learn you know when it's the right time
and take chances and when it's time to
check it down and move on down the road
you've got four interceptions over the
last two seasons that's 847 attempts Sam
Donald for interceptions last night in
32 attempts
I mean it's remarkable stuff with what
you're doing so maybe maybe the exact
sciences throw it exactly where you want
to throw it and make sure you have
receivers that are able to contest you
know each ball that you throw its
percentages you know you just play in
the percentage of the highest percentage
pass on each play and you know and new
that goes along with lowest interception
percentage per throwing you know I've
been been pretty good at that over the
years taking care of the ball you know
that was kind of how I grew up in the
game was knowing if I didn't take care
of the ball I was gonna get benched you
know in high school in junior college at
Cal you know and you just kind of knew
that was the way you need to play you
know and didn't want to play timid or
scared so I had to learn the really time
on my feet with the routes and so the
more accurately until on time and
you know try and eliminate those you
know those really bad decisions that
lead to bad picks well I have you on
next time you have a perfect game
hopefully it's not 12 years from now
thank you
you might be around I might not be
around but hey great to talk to you
thank you
that's Aaron Rodgers joining it you got
30 seconds to hit me with the pie Todd
so we've run out into the man cave quick
quick and how much time do we have you
got about 15 seconds Todd as you take
the man outside yeah you're gonna hit me
with it or we pretend we're gonna do it
right here how much time do we have how
much time for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
stream for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]